none okay plain you're a 17 year old
girl I was called and I'm going to
become a nun and there's really nothing
that you can say that's going to make me
change my mind
good afternoon all of you since
unfortunately God can't be here to run
this convent himself my voice will serve
as a stand-in for him you'll be spending
the next six months as postulants after
that move into the novitiate any
question put your hand down sister
postulants don't have questions and you
are free to go home what is this you're
reading something to do with this
Vatican 2 our Pope has suddenly turned
himself into some sort of reform well
that's a good thing perhaps change do
you think the churches need a change I
happen to think the church is perfect
the way you doing
are you still couraging all of your
wishes for extreme acts of penance I
would like you to use the discipline
I've got to start I don't think you
really understand do you
we're not supposed to think about each
other because we're not here for each
other we are here only for God maybe I
could just touch your horse you can
really not such a touch like that phone
is going on here she looks like she's
dying I think it's a wrong with you to
keep us in the dark the church gave me
my work my community even my identity
and now the church is trying to
invalidate all that saying none of it
matters - my question is what is it that
really does still matter
you